The most important skill
of a developer is not
programming in itself,
but actually how to use
Google properly.
A lot of answers are
already there on the internet.
A lot of algorithms are written.
A lot of libraries are present.
A lot of things
Have already been done
your job as a programmer.
Mostly is never to come up with
something innovative or
something extremely brand-new,
but your job is to
glue together, a bunch of
systems, which are not working
together initially,
but your job is to
just make sure that these
systems work together.
You can find these existing
systems, maintained well
maintained systems
through Google and you can
find how to link them
together with Google
as well.
But most people, I don't know
why shy away from Google.
I'm the kind of person who will
Google a topic and then
open 10
top 10 links in 10, different tabs
and then take the intersection of
everyone.
Why?
Because this helps me
to remove the bias from all the
other people,
which have written a particular
piece of content.